I think I think this goes back to like
another thing as well I don't know if
this is like any way related right but I
think one thing I've always just not
hated but just felt a little bit
uncomfortable with was kind of like
being the center of attention and I I I
don't know the podcast I don't know how
ironic this is I don't know how ironic
this is you're about 130 episodes
I still had a bunch of shows but I
[ __ ] hate being the center of
attention I don't know because like
there's a very clear distinction between
a center of attention when performing
yeah and the center of attention in your
personal life yes and to me right I love
being the center of attention when I'm
when I'm I'm performing or doing stuff
I'm sure we all do yeah well it's ego
stroke very nice yeah personal life it's
like all right sometimes yeah sometimes
no yeah I sometimes like it sometimes
I'm like no yeah yeah but like for
example for example what I mean for
example like birthday parties right like
do do you like having a birthday party
for your birthday specifically set up
all right all right for you I got an
opinion right right you know what I mean
you know what I mean no I think the
birthday party the entire Vibe is up to
whoever's organizing it or you yeah like
you can make a birthday party feel like
a normal party just with the excusive
it's my birthday yeah you know and
that's how I like it where it's like hey
let's all get together it's just an
excuse to get everyone in the same room
yeah I'm not about to be like hey guys
let's toast to me tell me what you love
about me show me your presence there are
people like that I don't know and that's
where I'm like bro come on
yeah I I love that Vibe like that
birthday party Vibe where it's just like
any excuse for everyone together
everyone you come out in the same room
and just hang out but I've also had
birthday parties and been to birthday
parties where it's just like guys it's
this guy's birthday guys
so this guy's and I just I I hate that
feeling having a day that is just
centered around you basically I just I
just I it was I think it's selfish it
was something that just never I never
felt comfortable with you know so you
see it's selfish and I think like a lot
of people argue being like well it's the
one day of the year you can be selfish
no right so you know everyone's having a
birthday 24 7. you know what I mean
you're not special
like yeah you can have a day why are you
gonna make the day about you all right
like you you can it can be your day
without me without putting down everyone
else yeah yeah before someone turns out
to your party they're probably doing
chores doing laundry they don't give the
fact that it's your birthday you know
what I mean like everyone's just you
know hey I'll especially as an adult I
just think that like you it can be your
day without making it like everyone you
forcing on everyone else that it's your
day yes yeah yeah I agree I think you
can have a nice day have the perfect day
you want yeah but you know just just let
that see like that's what I that's what
I really appreciated about my birthday
this year right because like it was
while we're on tour and we were doing a
show in Ohio
of all days and uh
and like and to me that was like the
perfect scenario for like a birthday
party right because it was like it
wasn't like the entire show was about oh
it's Joey's birthday today [ __ ] it
was like just a thing that was just
tacked on at the end I didn't even
[ __ ] know about it I got a python in
my face yeah it might in my opinion that
was like the best birthday party yeah
because it's like I wasn't the center of
attention I was just like a little
tackle thing where it's like by the way
yeah it's Joey's butt yeah you know
because the re the reason I bring that
up is you know having a day centered
around you gives me the same kind of
feeling of just like getting a surprise
gift or something where it's just like I
I'm getting now all the eyes are on you
yeah yeah I'm I'm getting attention from
like people around me and everything
like that and I'm just like I I was just
comfortable just chilling and just just
hanging out and not saying it's exactly
the same thing like I'm trying to like
trying to like understand why but I'm
just saying it kind of gives me like the
same feeling of just like oh I didn't
expect this um not that I'm ungrateful
about it it's just I don't know how to
handle it or deal with it and that's
completely just a me thing it's it's a
completely like that as well yes I was
gonna say I was like because it feels
like weirdly like it's very easy to be
like hey I'm on camera all day I got so
much attention I'm like this time let's
get this one out
of some attention today meanwhile I post
15 Vlogs and then [ __ ] stream for six
you know what I mean like I feel like
there's a bit ironic for me to be like
no I'm good I was like you know I don't
get enough in my mind is probably it is
probably stem from I get enough
attention I'm chill with that yeah yeah
but I wonder if I didn't do this would I
want more attention I think yeah no I've
been kind of the same as like not not
ever since I was a kid or anything
because I feel like it's not up until a
certain age where you become self-aware
about that kind of [ __ ] where you start
you realize being like Oh okay maybe I
don't want all the attention for my like
you know because like when you're
[ __ ] the inverse yeah well like when
you're [ __ ] five years old right like
you're not gonna be like guys play pens
on me I'm not I'm not the host or
anything just go have fun like you know
of course you know like you don't have
that kind of self-awareness but like
it's not until I feel like you're around
I want to say like 13 14 like when you
enter like high school or middle school
where you start to realize you either
turn into the kid that wants to be the
center of attention or you turn into the
kid that doesn't yeah man I had this
fantastic English teacher okay that's
just right she was like the best English
teacher man was she angry though like
but like you know when some I don't know
if you ever had these teachers then they
were super angry but not because they
were just life wasn't going that way
they were [ __ ] angry because you
weren't listening and they were very
passionate about it right right she
cared so much about English and teaching
it yeah and it was like she was
terrifying she was by far the scariest
teacher like all the like everyone was
scared of her and she used to go off and
I for somebody's always stuck with me it
was like if a kid was like making noise
and [ __ ] she would just tear into them
in front of the whole class and be like
oh oh Charlie is it because you don't
have enough attention at home that you
want to try and get some attention in
the classroom
and she would just destroy him and go
into them what's wrong with these kids
I'm like 12. oh [ __ ] you know that's
something when a kid traumatized kid
would just like do some [ __ ] she'd be
she would always just rinse how they
wanted the tension they weren't getting
it at home yeah so it's like oh so
you're not getting enough at home so you
decide to ruin my classroom trying to
get attention in your pathetic life or
something like that you go off dude
excuse me holy [ __ ] she's awesome she
was so good at teaching English yeah
it's very fun okay no I get it now I
okay yeah I'm I'm proud of the code so
the point was that yeah that stuck with
me and the kids want attention and that
you realize you don't want attention
what you do and what you're doing yeah
okay that's why I brought that out right
what what up what gives me happiness and
what gives me what gives God is just
learned right now he's like I figured
out yeah I've I've just I've just been
it's like lost me I'm just like why I've
just been trying to like [ __ ]
psychoanalyze my mind to be like why am
I so why am I such a [ __ ] idiot why
am I so [ __ ] difficult with the
simplest of things right yeah
um yeah for me like what actually gives
me happiness is making the people around
me happy seeing the people around me
happy so when protagonist so so when so
when the goal is to make me happy and to
like when people are like actively
trying to make me happy by just doing a
nice thing or something that just feels
weird to me because my happiness comes
from just seeing people around me happy
right yeah that is the most Harem
protagonists
happiness comes from giving you a gift
which is what you said
that's the Paradox I'm stuck in right
now Connor I don't know how to escape
by being upset about receiving the gift
you're making them upset oh no no no no
no no we're not I'm not I'm not I feel
bad you feel better no I feel pressured
you feel pressured yeah maybe that'll
make them upset yeah maybe actually it's
it's and again it's it's literally I'm
like like I said I'm not upset it's kind
of like you just break me where you just
put me into like a logic loot right I'm
just like I don't know what to feel I
know I should feel great and then like
and then like I get blue screens
that's me with social interaction I
guess
yeah I don't know it's it's I always try
and like psychoanalyze and try and
figure out why the [ __ ] I like think
certain ways or do certain things I'm
like yeah what what made me think this
way because yeah you hear what other
people think and I'm like oh why do I
not why do I not yeah why do I not think
that way yeah why do I not why like why
is it where that I differed in terms of
that yeah